الان للمزيد مشاهدينا منك يا مفضله خاص
عبد القادر
عبد القادر نقف معك عند اخر تطورات
الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
مرحبا رفيق هنا الاوكرانيون شعبا وقياده
منتشرون بعضا الى صحه التعبير منتشرون
بحجم وعدد العمليات العسكريه التي نفذوها
وحققوها في الاونه الاخيره القياده
العسكريه الروسيه تتحدث عن مهاجمه
واستهداف مدينه مدينه كولغا يعني بغرب
موسكو التي استهدفت بمسيره
بصاروخ معدل من نوع اس 200 حسب حاكم
المدينه الذي قالها عبر صفحته على
التيليجرام ان الدفاعات الجويه اعترضت
الصاروخ دون تحقيق او تسجيل اي خسائر سواء
الماديه او بشريه ايضا شبه جزيره القرم او
القرمه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ عام
2014 تعرضت لهجوم مكثف
باكثر من 42 مسيره حاكم مدينه صفاقول
الساحليه قال انه على ما يبدو ان الجيش
الاوكراني كان يريد ضرب بعض النقاط المهمه
العسكريه في المنطقه الساحليه خاصه من جهه
بحر ازوف لكن الى حد الان لم نعرف حجم
الخسائر مثل ما تفضلت رفيق في عيد
الاستقلال عيد الاستقلال اوكرانيا
تحدثت او تحدثت القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه عن تنفيذ عمليه نوعيه وهامه
جدا في شبه جزيره القرم قامت بها البحريه
الاوكرانيه
والمخابرات ايضا موسكو العمق عمق موسكو او
عمق روسيا باتا باتا يستهدف بسهوله حيث
استهدفت او استهدفت موسكو بمسيرتين ليله
الساعات الساعات النهار الاولى والليله
الاخيره دون تسجيل اي اي خسائر من الجانب
الاوكراني تحدثت هان مليار ونائبه وزير
الدفاع عن صعوبه العمليه في الشرق تقول ان
الجيش الروسي يحاول اختراق منطقه كومبياس
وشرق لمان لكن الان الجيش الاوكراني يتصدى
تقول ايضا انه
بعض السفن الحربيه قصفت مجموعه من السفن
او الزوارق المسيره في المياه المتخمه
لشبه جزيره القرم لكن اعترفت بصعوبه
العمليه العسكريه الميدانيه رفيق الان
باتت اخبار المسيرات في الجو
والزوارق المسيره بحرا تغطي كثيرا على
الاخبار القادمه من جبهات القتال لكن كل
هذا يغري الان ويجعل يضاعف من سعاده
الاوكرانيين منذ وصولنا الى هنا كنا نتحدث
بشكل مستمر مع الاوكرانيين يقولون انهم
منتشون وسعداء بالنتائج التي بات يحققها
الهجوم المضاده الذي اطلقته او اطلقه
الجيش الاوكراني منذ مداح شكرا جزيلا لك
يا عبد القادر درماس مفضل الخاص على كل
هذه التف